our blood vessels supply every part of
our body with nutrients and oxygen in a
complex branching system of tiny tubes
it said that laid end to end one
person's veins arteries and capillaries
would stretch 100,000 kilometers enough
to encircle the earth two and a half
times after they've been measured using
lasers recreated in plastic and seeded
with specially grown body cells these
artificial versions of natural blood
vessels could serve as replacement parts
they are urgently needed their bday is
Isaac claiming the need for such small
blood vessel systems or small
substitutes can't be currently met today
you can only take small vessels from
elsewhere in the patient's body but
especially in cases of heart attack
those tiny vessels are needed to replace
clogged vessels so at some point these
artificial blood vessels could be very
helpful Princeton Affairs Anatole 2004
fraunhofer Institute's are working
together to make that vision a reality
Kirsten borchers team faces huge
challenges one of the biggest ones is
finding the right mixture of polymer
materials to make the tubes this Little
flask contains an awful lot of work it's
not just one component but a composition
of various substances and even once
we've optimized the mixture we'll have
to see afterward whether the hardened
plastic is too brittle or too soft we
are constantly experimenting with new
combinations of materials these are Matt
VI composites Jana movida moy offsets
blood vessels are flexible highly
resilient and they constantly regenerate
those are exacting demands on a plastic
implant which also has to be long
lasting for years the research team has
been fine-tuning the right mixtures of
materials that can be processed with
laser light
a healthy heart pumps about 10,000
liters of blood through the arteries
every day coronary arteries can be
replaced by vessels from the leg in a
bypass operation but removing a section
of artery longer than 10 centimeters
poses severe health problems the
researchers hope their laser technology
can help each pulse of light hardens the
plastic the polymerized plastic forms
with a spatial precision of a thousandth
of a millimeter layer by layer the
process produces small three-dimensional
tubes the scientists are working on them
to imitate blood vessels ever more
closely so far however these are just
models the smaller the vessels the
harder it is to simulate them tiny
deviations in the branching could hinder
the flow of blood and lead to deposits
and clogging the body registers plastic
as a foreign body and tries to reject it
to fool the immune system Kirsten
borchers pipettes bio molecules into the
artificial vessels the idea is that
patient's own cells will adhere to them
listen even def is on that's the oba we
have to biology's the surfaces of the
material so that the body no longer
recognizes it as plastic one way of
doing that is to put a layer of
biological molecules or cells on the
surfaces and of course we try to design
a material whose mechanical properties
resemble those of a real blood vessel
and that is incredibly difficult phase
forehead on Desert Sun garbage village
in a bioreactor blood vessel cells are
being settled on the inner walls of the
artificial vessels here all the factors
that influence the process can be
precisely controlled and varied as
needed only once the cells have been
successfully seeded are the conditions
met for optimal and disturbance free
blood flow the inside surfaces of the
artificial blood vessels are processed
to make it easier for bio molecules to
adhere to them after the cells are
settled on the walls each tube is
subjected to a careful quality control
the cells have been treated with a
fluorescent pigment the colored light
makes them visible under the microscope
a moment is at the moment we are on the
way to growing cells on these surfaces
but we still have a long way to go
before we can be certain that the cells
will stay there and then we need
clinical studies and animal experiments
a lot remains to be done as no future
tomb they may take years to come to
fruition but arteries based on plastic
represent a great chance for medicine
[Music]